In the last video, I touched on
the idea of a sigma bond.
And that was a bond-- well, let
me draw two nucleuses and
let me just draw one
of the orbitals.
Let's say this is an sp3
hybridized orbital, and that's
on this atom and this is kind of
this big lobe right there.
And then this guy has an sp3
hybridized orbital as well.
That's the small lobe,
and then that's the
big lobe like that.
A sigma bond is one where
there's an overlap kind of in
the direction in which the
lobes are pointed.
And you might say, well, how can
there be any other type of
bond than that?
Well, the other type of bond,
so this right here-- let me
make this clear.
This right here is
a sigma bond.
And you say, well, what other
kind of bond could there be
where my two orbitals overlap
kind of in the direction that
they're pointing?
And the other type of bond you
could have, you can imagine if
you have two p orbitals.
So let me draw the nucleus of
two atoms, and I'll just draw
one of each of their
p orbitals.
So let's say that that's the
nucleus and I'll just draw
their p orbitals.
So a p orbital is just
that dumbbell shape.
Let me draw them a little
bit closer together.
So a p orbital is that
dumbbell shape.
So let me draw this guy's--
one of his p orbitals.
I want to draw it a little bit
bigger than that, and you'll
see why a second.
So one of his p orbitals
right there.
It comes out like that.
And then this guy over here also
has a p orbital that is
parallel to this p orbital,
so it goes like that.
Let me draw that other one
a little bit straighter.
It goes-- I want it to overlap
more, so it goes like that.
I think you get the idea.
So here, our two p orbitals are
parallel to each other.
This, you can imagine, these are
sp3 hybridized orbitals.
They're pointing
at each other.
Here, they're parallel.
p orbitals are parallel to each
other, and you see that
they overlap on this kind of
top lobe here and in this
bottom lobe here.
And this is a pi bond.
Let me make this clear.
And this is one pi bond.
So you could call it a pi,
literally, with the Greek
letter pi: pi bond.
Sometimes you'll see this
just written as pi bond.
And it's called a pi bond
because it's the Greek letter
for essentially p, and we're
dealing with p orbitals
overlapping.
Now sigma bonds, which are
what form when you have a
single bond, these are stronger
than pi bonds; pi
bonds come into play once you
start forming double or triple
bonds on top of a sigma bond.
To kind of get a better
visualization of how that
might work, let's think
about ethene.
So it's molecular structure
looks like this.
So you have C double-bonded to
C, and then each of those guys
have two hydrogens.
So let me draw what it would
look like, or our best visual,
or our best ability to kind
of conceptualize what the
orbitals around the carbon
might look like.
So first I'll draw the sp2
hybridized orbitals.
So let me just make it very
clear what's going on here.
So when we were dealing with
methane, which is literally
just a carbon bonded to four
hydrogens, and if I actually
wanted to draw it in a way that
it kind of looks a little
three-dimensional with a
tetrahedral structure, it
might look like this.
This hydrogen is pointing
out a little bit.
This hydrogen is kind of in
the plane of the page, and
then maybe that hydrogen is
behind it, and then you have
one hydrogen popping up.
That's methane.
And we saw that these were all
sp3 hybridized orbitals around
the carbon, and then they each
formed sigma bonds with each
of the hydrogens.
We saw that in the last video.
And when we drew its electron
configuration, in order for
this to happen, carbon's
electron configuration when
bonding in methane needed
to look like this.
It needed to look like 1s2.
And then instead of having 2s2
and then 2p2, what you
essentially have is-- let me
try it this way, actually,
even better.
Let me write this better.
In 1s, you had two electrons,
and then instead of two s's,
you had two electrons and on
each of the p's, you had one,
the s's and the p's all got
mixed up and you had a 2sp3
hybridized orbital, another
2sp3 hybridized orbital,
another 2sp3 hybridized
orbital, and then
another one, sp3.
Normally, when carbon's sitting
by itself, you would
expect a 2s here, and then
you'd have a 2p in the
x-direction, a 2p in the
y-direction, and then a 2p in
the z-direction.
But we saw in the last video,
they all get mixed up and they
all have a 25% s-character,
and a 75% p-character when
carbon bonds in methane and the
electrons kind of separate
out in that situation.
When you're dealing with the
carbons in ethene, remember,
eth- is for two carbons and
ene-, because we're dealing
with an alkene.
We have a double bond here.
In this situation, the
carbon's electron
configuration when they
bond in ethene
looks more like this.
So you have your 1s, and
the 1s orbital is
still completely full.
It has two electrons in it.
But then in your 2 shell, I'll
just write-- let me do this in
a different color.
So in our 2 shell, I'll show you
what I mean in a second.
I'm not writing the s or p's so
far on purpose, but we're
going to have four electrons
just like we had before.
We're still forming
four bonds.
We're going to have these
four unpaired electrons.
We're still forming one, two,
three, four bonds with each of
the carbons, so they're going
to be separated out.
But in this situation, instead
of all of them being a
mixture, kind of one part s,
three parts p, the s mixes
with two of the p orbitals.
So what you have is
2sp2 orbital.
So you can imagine that the s
orbital mixes with two of the
p orbitals.
So now it's one part
s, two parts p.
And then one of the p orbitals
kind of stays by itself.
And we need this p orbital to
stay by itself because it is
going to be what's responsible
for the pi bond.
And we're going to see that
the pi bond does something
very interesting to
the molecule.
It kind of makes it unrotatable
around a bond axis.
And you'll see what I
mean in a second.
So let me see if I can, in three
dimensions, draw each of
these carbons.
So you have-- let me do
it a different color.
You have this carbon
right there.
So let's say that's
the nucleus.
I'll put a C there so you
know which carbon
we're dealing with.
And then I'll draw-- you could
assume that the 1s orbital,
it's really small right
around the carbon.
And then you have these
hybridized orbitals, The 2sp2
orbitals, and they're all going
to be planar, kind of
forming a triangle, or I guess
maybe a peace sign on some
level, but I'll try to draw it
in three dimensions here.
So you have one, this is kind
of coming out a little bit.
Then you have one that's
going in a little bit.
And then you have-- and they
have another lobe a little bit
on the other side, but I'm
not going to draw them.
It'll complicate it.
They still have characteristics
of p, so
they'll have two lobes, but one
is bigger than the other.
And then you have one that's
maybe going in this side.
So you can imagine that this is
kind of a Mercedes sign if
you drew a circle around
it, on its side.
So that's this carbon
right here.
And, of course, it has
its hydrogens.
So you have this
hydrogen there.
And so this hydrogen might
be sitting right here.
It just has one electron
in its 1s orbital.
You have this hydrogen
up here.
It's sitting right over there.
And now let's draw
this carbon.
This carbon will be sitting--
I'm drawing it
pretty close together.
This carbon will be sitting
right there.
He has his 1s orbital.
They have the exact same
electron configuration.
He has his 1s orbital right
around him, and then he has
the exact same configuration.
Either of these guys, we've so
far only-- or in this first
guy, I've only drawn
these first three.
I haven't drawn this
unhybridized p orbital yet.
So I'll do that in a second.
But let me draw his bonds.
So first of all, he has this,
or you could imagine, that
bond right there, which would
be an sp2 hybridized bond.
Let me do that in
the same color.
So he has this bond right here,
which would be an sp2
hybridized bond,
just like that.
And notice, this is
a sigma bond.
They overlap in kind of the
direction that they're
pointing in.
That's the best I could
think about it.
And then he's got these two
hydrogens, so one-- he's got
this guy in the back, and then
there's one in the front.
I'll draw it a little bigger so
it's kind of pointing out
at us, right?
And then we have this hydrogen
is sitting right over here.
And these are also sigma bonds,
just to be very clear
about things.
This is an s orbital overlapping
with an sp2
orbital, but they're kind of
overlapping in the direction
that they're pointed, or kind of
along the direction of each
other, of the two atoms. This
is a sigma bond, sigma bond,
and then we have this hydrogen
in the back, which is also
going to form a sigma bond.
So everything I've drawn
so far is a sigma
bond, so that, that.
Maybe I don't want to make this
picture too-- so I can
just put sigma bond there, sigma
bond there, sigma bond
there, sigma, sigma.
So far I've drawn this bond,
this bond, this bond, this
bond, and this bond, all
of those sigma bonds.
So, what happens to this
last p orbital for
each of these guys?
Well, that's going to be kind
of sticking out of the plane
of the Mercedes sign, is the
best way I can describe it.
And let me see if I can do
that in a color that I
haven't done yet.
Oh, maybe this purple color.
So you can imagine
a pure p orbital.
So a pure p orbital, I'm going
to need to draw it even bigger
than that, actually.
A pure p orbital, it normally
wouldn't be that big relative
to things, but I have to
make them overlap.
So it's a pure p orbital that's
kind of going in, maybe
you can imagine, the z-axis,
that the other orbitals are
kind of a Mercedes sign
in the x, y plane.
And now you have the z-axis
going straight up and down,
and those bottom two have
to overlap so let
me draw them bigger.
So it looks like that and
it looks like that.
And they're going straight
up and down.
And notice, they are
now overlapping.
So this bond right here
is this bond.
I could've drawn them in either
way, but it's that
second bond.
And so what's happening
now to the structure?
So let me make it very clear.
This right here, that is a pi
bond, and this right here is
also-- it's the same pi bond.
It's this guy right here.
It's the second bond
in the double bond.
But what's happening here?
Well, first of all, by itself it
would be a weaker bond, but
because we already have a sigma
bond that's making these
molecules come closer together,
this pi bond will
make them come even
closer together.
So this distance right here is
closer than if we were to just
have a single sigma
bond there.
Now, on top of that, the really
interesting thing is,
if we just had a sigma bond
here, both of these molecules
could kind of rotate around
the bond axis.
They would be able to rotate
around the bond axis if you
just had one sigma bond there.
But since we have these pi bonds
that are parallel to
each other and they're kind of
overlapping and they're kind
of locked in to that
configuration, you can no
longer rotate.
If one of these molecules
rotates, the other one's going
to rotate with it because
these two
guys are locked together.
So what this pi bond does in the
situation is it makes this
carbon-carbon double bond-- it
means that the double bonds
are going to be rigid, that you
can't have one molecule
kind of flipping, swapping these
two hydrogens, without
the other one having
to flip with it.
So you wouldn't be able to kind
of swap configurations of
the hydrogens relative
to the other side.
That's what it causes.
So, hopefully, that gives you
a good understanding of the
difference between sigma
and pi bond.
And if you're curious, when
you're dealing with-- just to
kind of make it clear, if we
were dealing with ethyne, this
is an example of ethene, but
ethyne looks like this.
You have a triple bond.
And so you have each side
pointing to one hydrogen.
In this case, one of these, so
the first bonds, you can
imagine, so these bonds
are all sigma bonds.
They're actually
sp hybridized.
Your 2s orbital only mixes with
one of the p's, so these
are sp hybrid orbitals forming
sigma bonds, so all of these
right here.
And then both of these-- let me
do this in different color.
Both of these are pi bonds.
And if you had to imagine it,
could imagine another pi bond
kind of coming out of the page
and another one here coming
out of the page and into the
page, out and into the page,
and they, too, are overlapping,
and you just have
one hydrogen pointing out
in each direction.
Maybe I'll make another
video on that.
So, hopefully, you--